dès le jardin on comprend que c'est noël
au château de breteuil
pour découvrir l'ensemble des
décorations jean-emmanuel chars aux
administrateurs de la demeure nous la
fait visiter le circuit sera décoré dans
cette ambiance festive jusqu'à la fin
des vacances de noël
c'est un travail de plus de 15 jours
réalisée par lydie paillis de la
jardinière et pula da silva l'intendant
dans la salle à manger du personnel du
château
l'ambiance qui reconstituait s'est
déroulé en mai 1905 lorsque le roi
edouard vii d'angleterre est venu
déjeuner au château
son chauffeur est reçu à table par le
personnel qui leur soient dignement
on a en plus évidemment l'a fait les
décors de noël avec ce magnifique sapin
est un thème où j'ai cette année dans
celle du château sont proposés à la
visite et reconstitue une histoire et
donc c'est l'ambiance des luttes siècle
du 20e siècle et reconstituer la
maîtresse de maison très jolie robe est
descendu superviser les derniers
préparatifs pour le déjeuner donné ses
consignes aux chefs cuisiniers
quand on monte les étages on arrive dans
les pièces des propriétaires avec une
table de noël ou curieuses invité sur
fond rouge qui côtoie barbe-bleue le
prince charmant cendrillon ou le marquis
de carabas pièce maîtresse est année une
robe de réveillon dans le salon de
musique créée à partir de branches de
sapin
on est très content de cette nouveauté
on espère comme ça crée une nouvelle
robe chaque année à partir de 2018
chaque personnage du château a droit à
son décor spécial les les chats bottés
qui sont la mascotte du château d'idron
autre que l'on retrouve un peu partout
lentilles recul de la visite ici dans la
bibliothèque vous avez le chat libre et
son élève et qui sont très bien entouré
d'un magnifique village de noël
si sapins sont répartis tout au long de
la visite le plus somptueux étant
réservé à la grande galerie thompson
dans la grande galerie du château où il
ya les plus grands portraits de famille
et puis certains portraits royaux effet
dans cette pièce que nous avons mis le
plus grand sapin
il fait 4 mètres cinquante de hauteur et
puis de l'autre côté de la cheminée le
père noël est un fauteuil attendent les
visiteurs qui veulent se faire prendre
en photo la visite du château se fait
tous les après midi et pour les vacances
scolaires des commandes d infoprint